[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerradas
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana con un programa
dedicado al 14 de febrero a la fecha de
san valentín pero con el contexto de la
pandemia es por ello que nos preguntamos
hoy cómo es el amor y también el sexo en
tiempos de kobe me acompañan para ello
tres invitados les presento va a ser muy
interesante el programa de hoy un fal
que investigadora de la universidad de
parís especialista en cuestiones
feministas y el gp bienvenida jules que
tal medial evans es periodista co
fundadora de la revista feminista chic
magazine bienvenida hola victor hugo
ramírez doctor de la universidad
panthéon sorbonne a sobre política y
sexualidad bienvenido víctor hugo hola
que tal amor y sexo en tiempos de
lakovic hoy en primera plana
les planteo dos situaciones opuestas por
un lado miles de parejas que se aman a
distancia desde hace meses por la comida
naturales de países diferentes pongamos
estaban a miles de kilómetros cuando
estalló el virus el cierre de fronteras
y la anulación de vuelos pero también el
ejemplo contrario parejas cuya relación
se ha degradado bajo la presión del
confinamiento obligado pero no sólo
queremos hablar de amor también de sexo
de las consecuencias de la pandemia en
nuestra vida sexual la distancia social
y las limitaciones de movilidad están
condicionando nuestra manera de
relacionarnos han aumentado los casos de
depresión y de ansiedad y nos
preguntamos se debe todo esto a los
problemas ocasionados por el coronavirus
o más bien el coronavirus está delatando
carencias previas que ya existían en
nuestras sociedades vamos a repasar
algunas portadas y luego vamos a
plantear esta cuestión a nuestros
invitados revista 'now' sexo en tiempos
de kobe la pandemia complica las citas y
las relaciones poliamor osas jugar a
internacional a nuestros amores la
pandemia hace que los enamorados tienen
de creatividad e ingenio para poder
encontrarse
y también dedicó un número con esta
portada de una pareja besándose con
mascarillas sobre el titular libertad en
espera bueno los cambios que el
coronavirus se está produciendo en
nuestra sociedad en nuestras relaciones
amorosas en nuestras relaciones sexuales
es un tema que sabemos que está ahí pero
no se sabe cesc lo tocamos de forma
tangencial o no con la suficiente
profundidad y de hecho hay datos
reveladores hay un crecimiento
exponencial en aplicaciones de contactos
en consumo de pornografía en aumento de
separaciones que revelan todos estos
datos
jules yo creo que es revelada lo que ya
existe decir también relaciones de poder
también situaciones económicas porque
hay personas también solteras hay
personas se vio en la portada la revista
que tienen varias relaciones y sobre
todo yo creo que una cosa que se te pasó
es el aumento de la violencia de la
violencia doméstica de la violencia en
contra de las mujeres y de los niños y
las niñas porque a la par que aumenta la
el uso de pornografía también aumenta
las violaciones la violación es
incestuosas es ir en período de
confinamiento yo creo que eso
un periodo muy duro para muchas mujeres
y para muchos niños y niñas y aparte de
la crisis económica que también eso
afecta yo creo que en cierta forma la
líbido es decirle a la gente que está
haciendo fila para comer para recoger
comida está bueno tal vez considerar en
la fila pero hace de ahí lo que está muy
grueso si hay algo característico de
estos tiempos es que hemos perdido los
abrazos los afectos es algo muy
característico de este período de
confinamiento cómo se suple ese vacío de
afecto que es tan característico de esta
crisis lo estábamos hablando con un
lector que se suple con otras formas de
afectos que pensábamos que el afecto
sólo era abrazarse y besarse pero hay
otras formas como llamarse a tener
cuidado saber como los otros van y claro
que hay faltas pero hay creo otras
relaciones que se han creado este año
aquí que son muy interesantes también
nos han aproximado de una vez creo pero
de forma diferente
por un lado está el vacío de afectos y
por otro las separaciones en
confinamiento la pregunta es el estrés
de la pandemia como causa del problema o
la pandemia hace aflorar problemas que
ya estaban allí estoy de acuerdo con con
julie y con miriam en el sentido de que
el indicador de la violencia género es
una clave para entender las relaciones
el cambio las relaciones en este año y
también el vacío de afectos que yo no lo
calificaría como un vacío de afectos
porque los vacíos y los afectos están
ahí problemas que no son los afectos que
quisiéramos que estuvieran ahí tenemos
un aumento de estrés un aumento de
estrés postraumático de angustia de
frustración que obviamente van a afectar
nuestras relaciones cotidianas y estamos
a unas semanas de cumplir un año en que
muchas sociedades comenzaron el
confinamiento concretamente en europa y
aún nos falta mucho por estudiar todos
los efectos y las consecuencias en
nuestra vida diaria que va a tener esta
pandemia los espacios de interacción
están cerrados
bueno los trabajos limitados las
discotecas cerrados en confinamiento
esto hace que se profundicen las
relaciones en la sociedad de las
interconexiones y de las tecnologías no
es una
vimos esos espacios de una cierta forma
yo estaba pensando recordando un texto
de maría galindo del comienzo del
confinamiento que decía en neguémonos a
obedecer las órdenes absurdas además de
los gobiernos y yo creo que el hablar lo
que pasó le dio bastante la razón no
porque órdenes de separarnos de
alejarnos de poner la mascarilla de no
ponerla de eso del otro y ella decía
juntémonos en torno a las comunes bueno
ahora también hay cosas que sabemos del
montaje o no pero yo creo que todo lo
que nos permite romper con esa idea de
estar cada quien en su hogar en su con
su gente y otra vez volcarnos hacia los
y las demás yo creo que eso sería muy
importante seguimos pensando eso se nos
cuarto digamos este estamos mucho en lo
personal y yo con mi computador y con mi
computador yo a otra gente que está
solita frente a su computador se nos
cuarto si bien es cierto que los
confinamientos han demostrado que es lo
que han salvado vidas y hacer los gestos
bar barrera es decir por llevar
mascarillas tener una separación es
verdad que es complicado para el tema de
los afectos pero salvo
y eso también lo tenemos que tener en
cuenta al mismo tiempo
y las situaciones de estrés es una
explicación suficiente no sé para
entender el aumento del consumo de
pornografía algunos algunas webs hablan
de un 60 por ciento de aumento de este
consumo de pornografía o más bien lo que
es relevada lo que revela de nuevo el
confinamiento es que había una realidad
hay oculta que ahora seré superficie qué
pensáis de sí algo que yo existía y que
simplemente el coronavirus lo pone
encima de la mesa claro creo que para
cada situación es lo que pasó para la
gente en pareja reveló problemas o un
vínculo fuerte para algunas personas que
vienen sola
a veces reveló mucha como se dice
solicitud si se sentían muy muy solas
y al contrario hay personas que
descubrieron a la libertad de era muy
interesante creo que esa situación no
nos puso todos y todas frente a nuestras
elecciones de vidas amorosas también y
nos hizo pensar pero creo también que
al principio era interesante y nos
pensamos mucho y ahora estamos agotados
y no sabemos cómo cuándo va a acabar y
cuál mundo va a salir de todo esto
allí que penséis que hay una relación
entre el aumento del consumo de
pornografía y el miedo a la muerte a la
angustia provocado por esta realidad de
la comida
esta relación es muy freudiana esto que
estoy diciendo
haber visto es una pregunta muy
interesante yo no lo he pensado tanto
así pero lo que sí lo que sí es cierto
es que las personas que hemos perdido
seres queridos en esta temporada
tenemos una nueva visión no valoramos la
vida de una manera distinta y es por
ejemplo la teoría que comentaba el
investigador de yale sobre el posible
sodoma y gomorra el aros le va a
preguntar gusto
es posible es decir hay una nueva visión
sobre la vida de todos los que nos
quedamos ante tanto duelo que estamos
teniendo a nivel global
el que piensa a mí me extraña que al
principio del confinamiento una oferta
de productos culturales de películas
documentales etcétera obras de arte
geniales y yo creo que ahora ya eso se
quedó atrás de todo si sólo queda
pornografía avisarme una gente se queda
viendo pornografía porque lo que hay no
ahora yo creo que será más que nada en
varones que ha aumentado ese consumo sí
porque además el mundo de la pornografía
está hecho por hombres y muy asociado a
las reglas del patriarcado de cómo se
interpreta el sexo a través de los ojos
de los hombres no me parece me parece y
me parece que eso se vincula con el
destapamiento de tanta violencia sexual
que se da a través del mito y también de
la lucha contra los feminicidios que eso
también siguen a la par pero lo
interesante es que han aumentado las
prácticas de sexo virtual y creo que la
pornografía también hace parte de esos
juegos que hay gente que no lo hace
antes parejas separadas o solteros y
solteras o nuevas parejas que no se
pueden ver
y prácticas que ya existían
lo que estamos viendo es el sexting es
el intercambio de material sexual que a
lo mejor la pandemia ha reforzado claro
ya existía y sobre todo
entre los jóvenes y han aumentado mucho
porque era reunir a manera de estar en
contacto para ciertas personas y creo
que es interesante porque lo vemos con
un punto de vista de viejos y a veces
pensamos que es mal pero también son
otras prácticas nuevas hay que vivir hay
que lo que pasa también tiene un riesgo
que hay que tocar es decir cuando
intercambió ese tipo de material también
puede haber un chantaje detrás sobre
todo cuando eres una persona muy joven
que en lado hay que tener mucho cuidado
pero hay que verlo y cuestionarlo porque
están prácticas que ya existían y que
han aumentado un víctor yo creo que el
tema es muy muy controversial porque el
hecho de es una tendencia que ya venía
antes de la de la pandemia el hecho de
mostrar por ejemplo todas las
plataformas de pornhub twitter software
foundation y fans etcétera que que
tienen otras dinámicas de mostrar el
cuerpo y que muestran la producción de
contenidos pornográficos ya sea de un
lado como es mi libertad de mostrar mi
cuerpo de explotar mi propio cuerpo pero
también lo podemos negar que se trata la
pornografía y la industria pornográfica
del cuerpo de las mujeres de la
reproducción de un tipo de violencia
simbólica de violencia sexual clara y
que por eso es tan importante la
educación sexual y la educación en
afecto relacionado con tecnologías y
sobre todo para tener generaciones
aparte todas esas imágenes que dan
propiedad de los gafas y yo creo que eso
cada vez a muchos jóvenes habría que
dejarles esto muy claro que pueden
hipotecar su vida haciendo esto sí y
claro y esas imágenes decir
al mismo tiempo vemos la el aumento de
la vigilancia de todo lo que es la
circulación de información por internet
y por las redes entonces a mí me da
claro de repente tal vez me daría ganas
de aceptar o lo otro a través de esos de
esas redes pero luego voy pensando en
toda la gente que lo puede confiar oigan
crimen el llamado efecto de los felices
años 20 es decir que cuando todo esta
pandemia haya pasado esto va a ser una
especie de sodoma y gomorra que va a
haber un frenesí sexual como respuesta
al etapa poscrisis víctor
lo hizo un catedrático de la universidad
de yale no me lo está inventando es
cierto que después la especie humano
había vivido una nada fenómeno tan
global desde hace muchas décadas y si
miramos hacia lo largo de la historia
después de la primera guerra mundial
después de la segunda guerra mundial el
'baby boom' etcétera es decir si hay una
puede haber una especie de reacción y te
lo comentaba los que hemos tenido tanto
dolor este año los que hemos perdido
seres queridos si nos queda esta especie
de
y ver la vida de otra mayo transforma de
otra forma y valorar el instante y en
este valorar el instante puede haber
esta gratificación búsqueda de
gratificación instantánea está esta
búsqueda de ahora vamos a vivir la vida
y también con otro tipo de prácticas por
ejemplo el uso de sustancias
psicoactivas etcétera entonces quizá es
una es un escenario pero todavía estamos
muy muy esperando que cuáles van a ser
las consecuencias de estar me van a
permitir no son una pequeña pausa y en
unos instantes continuamos hablando de
amor y sexo en tiempos de comida que en
primera plana
[Música]
a
si no ha empezado su periodo vacacional
más relevante del calendario nacional en
un estado de semi normalidad aquí no
están vigentes las normas de
distanciamiento social pero tampoco se
ha producido el éxodo masivo que cada
año lleva a centenares de millones de
chinos a atravesar el país para reunirse
con sus familiares la razón es el
rebrote del norte del país en enero ya
sofocado pero que fue el perro en 10
meses y contó con más de 2000 casos eso
empujó al gobierno a desaconsejar todos
los viajes que no fueran estrictamente
necesarios y las autoridades dieron
descuentos en restaurantes en
atracciones turísticas locales
e incluso dinero en efectivo eso ha
conseguido que los viajes se hayan
reducido en un 60% con respecto a los
del año 2019 en pekín el templo del lama
ha estado cerrado ahí es donde se juntan
miles de chinos en el primer día del año
para quemar incienso y pedir buenos
deseos y también estaba cerrado el
tradicional mercado de comida del templo
de titan en pekín ha sido un día
grisáceo y pesado para dar la bienvenida
al año del buey
[Música]
la ciudad de nueva york ha querido
unirse a las celebraciones del año nuevo
chino bajo el signo del buey y durante
la noche estará iluminando sus edificios
más emblemáticos como por ejemplo el
oculus que están viendo detrás de mí o
la torre del famoso world trade center
además también se iluminará el edificio
más conocido en esta ciudad el empire
state que además estará ofreciendo
también una exposición en la quinta
avenida sobre la cultura china que
mantendrá hasta el próximo 10 de marzo
además se espera que los restaurantes
asiáticos de la ciudad estén ofreciendo
estos días un menú especial para las
celebraciones y que los estadounidenses
de origen chino se reúnan en las casas
para celebrar este año nuevo eso sí los
expertos advierten que siguiendo siempre
las medidas de seguridad por el kobe 19
[Música]
los coloridos festejos y los desfiles
que todos los años se realizan en
londres y en otras ciudades de
inglaterra para darle la bienvenida al
nuevo año chino se realizarán por
primera vez online dado que este país
continúa en su tercer confinamiento
nacional y las cifras de infección con
hobbits siguen siendo muy altas la de
londres se considera que es una de las
celebraciones más grandes fuera de
países asiáticos las calles del
chinatown han sido decoradas con el
tradicional rojo y con luces pero este
sector de el centro de la capital
británica está prácticamente vacío
algunos restaurantes se mantienen
abiertos pero solo para domicilios en su
tradicional mensaje para la comunidad
china
el primer ministro boris johnson dijo
que como el buey esta bestia fuerte y
perseverante el mundo seguirá en su
lucha en su batalla para derrotar al cob
y 19
[Música]
siempre que hay un líder asesinado
tenemos que pensar quién se beneficia
con mujeres que protagonizan la agenda
política económica social cultural del
mundo han conversado con los periodistas
de france 24 en español no es una moda
pasajera el feminismo con la forma de
ver la realidad
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellas hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
continuamos aquí en primera plana de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 esta semana hablando un problema muy
especial de san valentín el amor y el
sexo en tiempos de kobe tú lo hacemos
con la investigadora jules falqué miriam
leyva un periodista del chic magazine de
la revista víctor hugo ramírez doctor de
la universidad panthéon sorbonne a sobre
política y sexualidad estábamos hablando
antes de la pausa de si se va a producir
un llamado efecto de los felices años 20
cuando todo esto haya pasado es decir
que tengamos una especie de sodoma y
gomorra me entiende a mí cuando en una
etapa de pospandemia de un desenfreno
sexual
la teoría viene de un catedrático de la
universidad de yale ustedes comparten
que esto pueda pasar dicen que a lo
largo de la historia esto se puede
estudiar y que después de las pandemias
hay esa especie esa especie de necesidad
de efecto desenfreno a ver por qué la
cita completa es también en lo económico
exacto niveles pero que incluye por
supuesto el sexual claro y yo creo que
el sexual y también lo político porque
estaban pensando mientras la pausa
en como la gente salió a la calle
después en parís y en francia digamos
después del final del confinamiento las
marchas en contra de por ejemplo el
racismo y toda la situación de
injusticia había miles y miles de
jóvenes sobre todo en la calle y yo
pensé que están por una causa pero
también están porque quieren ver a gente
tal vez para acoger tal vez para lo que
sea pero digamos ver a gente antes mismo
de tener relaciones sexuales miriam y
solo para tomar copas bailar bailar es
algo que extraemos mucho creo hacer la
fiesta creo que vamos a valorizar más
esos momentos de encuentros entre
nosotros y nosotras y eso creo que va a
ser muy fuerte otro fenómeno de la
pandemia el de la formación de parejas
virtuales nacidas al calor de la
pantalla a las que les ha dado incluso
tiempo a romper antes de llegar a
conocerse en persona el este es el
estímulo permanente y la idealización en
la distancia que dan por resultado un
desencanto inevitable
me parece que ahora hay como la gente
ya no quiere más ni siquiera quieren ir
en las aplicaciones pero en fin es lo
que me parecen tales porque es el
invierno también y llevamos un año y tal
pero las cifras dicen que este año las
aplicaciones por ejemplo en el 'new york
times'
ahora decían que jeans que es una
aplicación de idate de beijing
hizo tres veces más cifra que el año
pasado así que si la gente lo usa mucho
es la única ahora es la única manera de
conocer la nueva gente
victorio yo creo que también en algún
momento nos vamos a adaptar de las
pantallas ya sea en los celulares la
tele porque debemos recordar que si no
se trata de que hayamos disminuido
nuestro trabajo presencial los que
tuvimos ese privilegio sino que nuestro
trabajo se metió directamente a nuestras
casas y implicó un trabajo de
de cuidados que sobre todo recae en las
mujeres y que va a modificar que han
modificado todas nuestras nuestras
relaciones cotidianas es decir ok si hay
una reacción también hacia las pantallas
hacia las aplicaciones pero también
estamos un poco saturados de la
actividad con las pantallas y con todo
tipo de de redes tengo más estadística
crecimiento de un 86 por ciento en venta
de artículos y juguetes sexuales durante
la pandemia en países como españa que
hay detrás de este crecimiento tan
exponencial de la compra de juguetes
sexuales igual la soledad porque parte
de los juguetes son para usar sola o
sólo no
creo que en la soledad y también las
parejas que no estaban acostumbradas
pasar tanto tiempo juntas he oído a
testimonios positivos también de parejas
que antes que se han de descubrir al
descubierto otra vez y creo que también
han usado juguetes
me parece oye pues a algunas cosas
buenas pues
y luego hasta un tema muy interesante
que es el del lenguaje no verbal no sé
hasta qué punto somos conscientes de que
nos estamos relacionando sin sonrisas
incluyendo cosas como la ironía ciertas
cosas que siempre han sido que siempre
han estado ahí a la hora de
relacionarnos y ahora no podemos jugar
con ellas que les parece todo este tipo
de lenguaje no verbal del que ahora no
tenemos y yo diría que una cosa la
mascarilla aunque es evidente esconde
mucho y verá alguna gente se ve mucho
mejor con la mascarilla y otra gente
otra vez entonces también pero digamos
es una cosa exposición a la pantalla por
lo menos poder ver a la cara de la gente
porque digamos en muchos aspectos y yo
en mi trabajo como docente cuando iba
todavía a dar clases yo veía a la gente
con mascarilla efectivamente no podía
ver bien quién era grande que cuando
empezamos las clases virtuales por lo
menos vi sus caras y me sorprendí
no sabemos de sobra que la pandemia va a
restablecer un nuevo orden mundial nos
replanteamos hablamos siempre de la
economía post pandemia la sociedad post
pandemia el mundo de la cultura pero no
les parece que no hablamos lo suficiente
de las relaciones post pandemia de cómo
van a ser esas relaciones por pandemia
que seguramente cambien en muchos
aspectos víctor completamente yo creo
que hay que preguntarnos si hay que
forzar a responder la pregunta de cómo
van a cambiar y en nuestros modelos de
relación por ejemplo el modelo de
familia nuclear es decir podemos sigue
siendo viable
cada persona busca establecer una pareja
y se vaya a buscar una casa
independiente autónoma que multiplica
las formas de consumo que ya
y que también tenemos una crisis
ecológica que recordarlo y todo esto que
nos lleva por ejemplo al otro lado del
día de sant martí que es el de la
amistad el día del amor y la amistad la
amistad que nuevas formas de cooperación
de solidaridad ha provocado esta
pandemia
que les parece una cuestión troncal el
de replantearnos que va a cambiar en
nuestras relaciones por ejemplo el mundo
de los cuidados que lo estamos viendo
tanto durante esta crisis sanitario y
estamos nombrando lo tanto vamos a tener
unas relaciones más basadas en los
cuidados creo que sí pero también hay
miedos nuevos en cuanto al contacto no
sé cómo vamos hay gente que tiene miedo
de tocar a otra gente y eso es nuevo no
sé cómo vamos a salir de eso espero que
que lo vamos a olvidar creo que hay
cosas universales intemporales como
tocarse besarse que que lo vamos a
aprender muy deprisa otra vez pero a
veces tengo un poco de miedo de que ya
no seamos humanos sabes y en cuanto al
cuidado si es un tema muy fuerte y que
ha tocado a las mujeres eso es un tema
de creemos
ha hablado mucho porque las mujeres eran
en primer primer frente a las enfermeras
y tal y las madres también es el peso de
los cuidados siempre ha recaído
efectivamente
y hay muchas discusiones lucha del
feminismo actual no de un reparto de
cuidados mucho más equitativa claro y
era me acuerdo la primera semana del
confinamiento yo estaba muy optimista y
optimista y pensaba que las parejas iban
a compartir más porque los hombres
estaban más en casa pero eso no pasó
para nada y las mujeres y las madres las
que tienen niños a todo peso sobre ellas
yo diría las investigaciones
desgraciadamente muestran que aunque se
reduzca el tiempo de trabajo de los
hombres no trabajan más en casa
fundamentalmente y yo diría ciertamente
mejor reparto del trabajo de cuidado y
del trabajo sucio en general digamos
porque es parte del cuidado del juicio
pero también mejor paga porque hay mucha
gente que lo hace porque es su profesión
antes un hombre dice
y yo sí que ayudo en casa ya que tiene
la cabeza hemos puesto en tela de juicio
algunos principios del amor romántico
durante este confinamiento hay gente que
le ha dado tiempo a replantearse ciertas
cuestiones por el hecho de estar a lo
mejor confinado y poder pensar sí claro
y también las palabras escribirse y
mandar mensajes y todo eso lo hemos
hecho mucho y creo que es un aspecto
positivo de dar utilizar de nuevo todo
lo escrito es hay una parte romántica
soy muy optimista me gusta a ver los
buenos lados de la vida pero sí creo que
hay algo también creo que ahora vamos a
pensar más en nuestra relación con los
encuentros del sexo y vamos a lo mejor a
elegir calidad en vez de cantidad lo que
lo que hicimos antes del confinamiento
hablamos de los cuidados hablamos de la
solidaridad cuántas veces hemos hablado
de ello durante la pandemia creen que
esto va a pertenecer o creen que más
bien el calor de la pandemia
hace aproximarnos estos conceptos para
luego volver a un individualismo isaac
exacerbado al que llamamos la nueva
normalidad que era más o menos la de
antes hoy espero que yo espero que lo
pensemos espero que después de esto
digamos ok fue una oportunidad es una
oportunidad para repensar nuestros
esquemas nuestras formas de
relacionarnos no sólo en tema de
violencia de género en tema de pareja y
un tema de cuidados pero ahí está la
oportunidad de ya la veremos si la
tomamos uno
jules a mí una cosa que me llama la
atención es que no estoy segura que va a
haber un después en dos sentidos primero
que no creo que vaya a ser de un día
para otro en el después y luego por lo
que veo yo también intentó hacer un
optimista pero no siempre lo logro y en
realidad lo que nos anuncian son varias
oleadas y luego de la misma pandemia
luego otras pandemias luego viene
desgraciadamente la crisis económica y
del medio ambiente entonces vendrá
herida no sé si realmente vamos a salir
de un día para otro y porque eso era la
ilusión del primer
en francia pero no se dio esa salida de
un día para el otro también hay países
que van a salir antes y otros que no
sabemos cómo va a pasar y puede demorar
mucho
lo de que la pandemia nos volvería más
buenos más solidarios algo también
aplicable a las relaciones a las
relaciones humanas esto lo compran o son
mucho más escépticos
demostremos quedo mucho en este tópico
de que la pandemia no se van a volver
muy buenos unas sociedades muy
solidarios
yo creo se trata de que nos vuelvan
buenos son malos sino de que las
condiciones materiales que vamos a tener
y lo vemos ya el aumento del desempleo
el aumento de la precariedad el aumento
en la violencia es decir realmente
podemos seguir con nuestras mismas
formas de vida y yo creo que ahí la
pregunta la tenemos que responder como
comunidades es que hay ciertamente que
no hay personas los estudiantes las
personas vulnerables que están sufriendo
cada vez más y que pueden llegar a un
nivel que ya no puedan seguir teniendo
los mismos niveles y los mismos estilos
de vida que nos va a obligar a pensar no
si queremos ser más buenos sino si
necesitamos ser más solidarios
en todos los aspectos de nuestras vidas
diarias lógicamente responder no a la
pregunta que plantea víctor es
obligatoriamente transformar nuestros
tipos de relaciones y esto es esto es
que es una revolución y una sociedad
cabal es realmente lo que necesitamos es
una revolución profunda del sistema
económico político social ecológico eso
es lo que se ve así desde lo que yo creo
que la conciencia era más fuerte al
comienzo en la pandemia en los primeros
días la gente dijo es por la lo que se
llama el barrio y toda esa cosa de la
industrialización del campo etcétera eso
hay que cambiarlo y luego se fue
diluyendo pero ahí está y hay que hay
que cambiar radicalmente de sistema si
no vamos al directo a ninguno revolución
de afecto revolución de relaciones como
serán nuestras relaciones pospandemia ha
sido muy interesante compartir con
ustedes este programa especial de san
valentín que hemos dedicado en primera
plana al amor al sexo a las relaciones a
los afectos ya cómo serán todas estas
cosas
a la vuelta de la esquina ha pasado
mañana como quien dice muchísimas
gracias a los tres y a todos ustedes
hasta la próxima semana quien en primera
plana gracias
[Música]
ah